est arrivée au Canada
en 2013 avec sa famille.
La jeune Ukrainienne
de 19 ans vit la pire
IANA SHAPOVALOVA
- C'est lourd... c'est lourd
de savoir que ma famille est
co
puis ils ont pas place
où est-ce qu'ils pourraient
rester.
- Elle n'a presque plus aucune
en Ukraine, seulement
quel v v vidéos que sa famille
lui envoie, qui la bouleversent
profondément.s,s,s,s,s,s,s,s,s,e
pas. Donc, mettons, il y a
une petite pause de 15 minutes,
ma
- Elle tente de faire venir
19 membres de sa famille
au Canada.
- Ça, c'est ma grand-mère
esesest, elle aussi,
elle est au sous-sol de
l'église.s s s s s s s s s s s s
sont interminables.
- Chaque attente, ça peut...
ça peut briser le coeur,
ça peu
une famille complètement.
Si c'est possible d'accélérer
ça a de l'importance.eeeeeeeeeee
est importante en tempsde guerr,
Nikolai, a été tué hier.
- Ils ont trouvé son bus,
qui était complètement brûlé,
les quatre personnes qui étaient
presque pas reconnaissables,
juste lui qui a été éééé
de l'auto, il a été reconnu.
- Sa femme et ses trntntntntnts
se cachent dans une église
de Marioupol.
- Je sais que mon frère est
ieieieieier, mais aujourd'hui,
je suis rentrée au travail
parce que je sais... je n'popop.
Présentement, ils ont
tout détruit, les maisons,
le travail... tout ce
qu'ils
- Olena, ébrs s s s s s s s s se
Ottawa d'accélérer le processus
pour rapatrier les réfugiés
ukrainiens. t t t t t t t t t tt
possible, ils vont arrêterd'ent,
ils peuvent commencer
la vie normale
- Son beau-frère, Peter Semikin,
se cache lui aussi. Sa femme
en Hongrie, en sécurité,
pour le moment.
"Je trouve ça d'd'd'd'd'd'être
loin de ma famille. Nous voulons
venir au Canada. Nous sommesysys
où on va se sentir en sécurité.t
à accélérer les processus
ukrainiens. Affaires mondiales
Canada n'a pas retourné
nos appels aujourd'hui.
Ici Marie-Michelle Lauzon